au vu de pressing et bilal taha bonjour
bilal bonjour philo mais nous commençons
par la france dimanche prochain en votes
élections législatives tout à fait ce
sont des élections cruciales puisqu'il
s'agit de savoir si le pays donne une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale au
président réélu emmanuel macron ou pas
mais cher philo mais ce scrutin ne
semble pas passionner les foules le
figaro on le voit titre en une menace
d'abstention record sur les élections
législatives avec ce sondage commandé
par le quotidien de droite seuls 46% des
français pourrait se rendre aux urnes et
cela confirme en fait une tendance de la
plongée de la participation pour ce
scrutin qui on le rappelle vise à élire
tous les députés de l'assemblée
nationale je vous donne quelques
chiffres en 1993 on avait 68 % de taux
de participation
en 2010 7 48% et donc cette année ça
pourrait être encore moins alors le
figaro s'est rendu dans la ville de
stains qui se trouve en seine saint
denis en banlieue parisienne la seine
saint denis est le département le plus
pauvre de france et où dixit le journal
on le voit aussi ici de nombreux
électeurs ne savent même pas qu'une
élection a lieu ce dimanche florilège
des paroles d'habitants recueillis dans
les rues de la ville il y a encore une
élection point d'interrogation je ne
vote pas car je veux me barrer d'ici ou
encore on nous distribue des tracts au
marché pendant les élections mais après
c'est toujours pareil on reste dans
l'âme
oui
l'un des habitants qui résident dans
cette ville depuis 60 ans lui résume la
situation je le cite les jeunes ici ne
croit plus en rien le figaro rappelle
enfin que lors de l'élection
présidentielle d'avril dernier les
habitants de cette ville de stains 40000
habitants ont plébiscité le candidat de
la france insoumise jean luc mélenchon
qui a obtenu dans cette ville 60 % des
voix c'est trois fois son score au
niveau national et jean luc mélenchon
chef de file de la gauche à ces
élections législatives il fait
d'ailleurs bilal et voulons relever une
campagne inédite il appelle a donné la
majorité à sa coalition pour qu'il
devienne premier ministre tout à fait à
tel point que pour le quotidien de
gauche libération jean luc mélenchon est
devenue l'obsession du parti des manuels
macron qui multiplierait les faits qui
nous le concernant je vous laisse
admirer la une du journal
donc je la lis un l'ephec news de la
macro ni deux points jean luc mélenchon
branche style des enfants voilà voilà
alors évidemment il s'agit d'une
outrancière 1 personne n'a jamais
prétendu que le leader de la france
insoumise manger des enfants donc le
quotidien explique sous son titre la
dynamique de la gauche unie et frais la
majorité présidentielle qui tentent de
diaboliser jean luc mélenchon à la
veille des législatives un kit à dire
n'importe quoi et donc dans une rubrique
intitulée
poker-menteur
libération liste 5 fait qu'ils n'usent
répandu selon le journal par emmanuel
macron ou son entourage je vous donne un
exemple avec cette déclaration du
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
daté du 1er juin citation tous les pays
qui ont mis en oeuvre un projet
similaire se sont retrouvés sous
programme de surveillance du fmi
quelques années plus tard le venezuela
la grèce ou l'argentine cela étant dit
les sondages ne sont pas si mauvais
forcément mauvais pour emmanuel macron
pas du tout puisque selon un sondage
réalisé cette semaine par le journal les
échos le président pourrait conserver la
majorité absolue c'est à dire entre
290 et 330 sièges la deuxième formation
pourrait être la coalition de gauche
lannux justement de jean luc mélenchon
avec 160 à 190 sièges et enfin la droite
des républicains centristes et udi avec
50 à 70 sièges on change totalement de
sujet on revient sur notre premier titre
de ce matin les états unis ou la
commission enquête parlementaire sur l
attaque contre le capital a commencé à
rendre cette conclusion conclusion
diffusé en direct sur de nombreux médias
oui et vous l'avez évoqué dans votre
édition avec sandrine cette commission
place donald trump je cite au centre
d'un complot visant à le maintenir au
pouvoir et dans une tribune d'opinion le
washington post lance une charge
virulente contre le parti républicain
pourquoi parce que finalement ce que
déclare le parti républicain c'est ça ne
sert à rien de faire cette commission et
encore moins de la diffuser dans les
médias puisque nous nos électeurs ne
changeront jamais d'avis et pour
l'éditorialiste du washington post à
n'est pas le but de cette commission de
faire changer les gens d'avis elle cite
la commission parlementaire qui sait a
eu lieu après le 11 septembre la
commission parlementaire qui a eu lieu
après pearl harbor et pour elle
finalement ces commissions
parlementaires ont simplement pour but
de d'établir des faits d'établir une
histoire pour que de tels événements ne
se reproduisent jamais merci beaucoup
mais là le tarab et pour votre revue de
presse que vous qui